[Noel] In the beginning…
-Aw, thank you very much.
-Is that better?
…there were 12.
So, Nicky, tell us about your beaver.
[all laughing]
[thunder rumbling]
-[Alison] Now…
-This is it, the storm is coming.
…there are three.
Let's see how I get on.
Ah, why is it doing that?
There can only be one winner.
To be honest, I don't know with it.
Patience.
Oh, no, I didn't dust 'em
in icing sugar, did I?
It's not your best shot.
[opening theme music playing]
[Dan] Oh, it's an empty tent now,
isn't it?
[Noel] Just three challenges stand
between the finalists
and the coveted Baking Show crown.
[Josh] Best of luck.
[Dan] Go, go, go, Josh.
[Noel] Josh's passion for precision
was obvious from week one.
I love the way one of her eyes
-is completely gone with the fringe.
-[Paul laughs]
[Noel] By week two, he had already
had the Hollywood handshake.
It's amazing.
[Noel] Every week,
he's delivered stunning showstoppers.
It's beautiful.
[Noel] Delivering him Star Baker,
-not once, but twice.
-[applause]
[Josh] Just want to have three
good last bakes that I can be happy with,
but we shall see.
[Alison] This year's first Star Baker Dan
has often made his life complicated.
So I am doing the aromatic flavours
-of a Thai green curry.
-What're you thinking?
[Alison] And it hasn't always
been successful.
It's sandy and dry.
[Alison] But he's fought back
from disappointment…
-These aren't baked.
-…winning more technical challenges
than any of his fellow finalists,
-the Hollywood handshake…
-That's beautiful.
…and was Star Baker again in Dessert Week.
I'd love to win it, but I'm against
these two little rugrats this weekend.
Such good lads,
I'm gonna have to really raise my game.
[Noel] Matty's time in the tent
did not begin well.
-Can't give that to anyone.
-[Noel] But he's listened…
-It looks like it was run over.
-[laughs]
…and learned.
The look of it is really very good.
-[Noel] Polishing decoration…
-Your box is beautifully engineered.
…and perfecting flavours.
The chilli is great in there.
[gasps, laughs]
[Noel] Despite a handshake
and winning Star Baker twice,
he's never won a technical challenge.
[Matty] I would say that I'm the underdog.
Everyone likes the underdog though, right?
[laughing] Please.
Welcome back to the tent, bakers,
for your last ever signature challenge.
The judges would like you to bake
eight exquisite highly decorative éclairs.
You should choose two different types
in terms of decoration and flavour.
Now remember, guys, this is the final,
so the judges would like you
to bake in the nude.
[Alison laughing]
And when Noel says judges, he means Prue.
[Prue and Noel chuckle]
-[mouths] Yes.
-You have two hours and 15 minutes.
On your marks…
-Get set…
-[in Jamaican accent] Bake!
[Josh] Can't believe
this is the last signature.
I'm nervous, hope these look all right.
[Matty] There's a lot of pride
for each one of us.
We play sport, we're competitive.
[Dan] When I play football,
I wear two pairs of socks.
I've got four pairs of underpants
on today. 'Cause I'll need 'em.
They've gotta make two different types
of éclairs and they've got to be perfect.
The pastry needs to be
really puffed up and crisp as anything.
But you want beautiful air holes inside
which you fill with cream or custard.
But the problem is you can add
too many creams and custards to it
and make it soggy.
[Prue] They've all had two Star Bakers,
they've all had a handshake
so they are absolutely level pegging.
And I haven't a clue who's going to win.
And if they wanna win,
start now with the éclair.
Hello, Dan.
-Hello.
-Good morning. You all right?
Tell us all about your éclairs.
So I'm doing, erm, strawberries and cream
and, er, a summer fruit punch jelly.
And for my second one, I'm doing
a salted caramel mascarpone cream
with a praline ganache on top.
-Sounds nice.
-Don't they sound good.
[Alison] Dan will top his
salted caramel and praline éclairs
with crisp tempered chocolate.
His strawberries and cream éclairs
will be decorated
with Chantilly cream and cubes of jelly.
Tell us about your choux.
It's one of my first pastries
I learnt to make
so I've got my set recipe,
and it never fails.
-[laughs]
-[Alison] So far.
-So far, yeah.
-[laughs]
[Alison] Josh is also hoping to fill
choux pastry with a taste of summer.
Is this your own fruit from your garden?
Well, it's not now because--
-No.
-Because I've used it all up.
-[laughs] You used all your fruit.
-There's none left.
-Now it's just barren.
-I keep bringing it and it's gone.
[Noel] What flavours?
[Josh] Coconut, mango, raspberry.
[Noel] Alongside his summery éclair,
Josh plans another
filled with coffee pastry cream
and topped with dark chocolate
and coffee icing.
[Josh] That's for my brother,
he's not a fruit lover.
Most of the things I've made recently,
he's not liked them.
What does he say? "That's all right"?
-Yeah, he'll try a bit…
-[laughs]
-Exactly like that.
-Thanks for the encouragement.
[Dan] You melt the butter, boil it.
Get your flour in
and beat the living daylights out of it.
[Alison] Unless the finalists
combine butter, milk and flour
with the perfect amount of egg…
[Josh] I'm a smidge under.
[Alison] …their choux will be loose,
creating flat soggy éclairs.
I've avoided choux pastry
like the plague up until this week.
[Noel] Matty's hoping to play it safe
with two classics,
Black Forest gateau éclairs
topped with a kirsch Chantilly cream
and banoffee éclairs,
featuring a walnut and pecan praline.
-You all right?
-I'm happy for you.
-[laughs]
-So happy that you're here.
You feel you could do this?
No, I've not given any of that a thought.
I never applied, so I never really
had that as a thought process.
You didn't apply for this?
No, Lara applied for me.
-Oh, I love Lara.
-[laughs]
He would never have applied for himself.
It's just not in his nature.
He's not braggy.
I wanted him to be
a part of something like this
to show to him how amazing he is.
Because doesn't matter
how much I tell him,
he doesn't believe me.
I don't actually understand
most of what he's made
if I'm absolutely honest.
Especially you,
'cause you're not a dessert person anyway.
No, so it's all a bit over my head.
His ability has obviously increased.
He made our anniversary cake
last year, didn't he?
Did he?
-Tell me. It's a lemon cake.
-Oh, yes! Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah. [laughs]
-Sorry, it was very nice. [laughs]
[Lara] He'll go to school,
-do after school clubs.
-[Matty] Perfect.
[Lara] He'll get in, start baking,
baking until we go to bed.
And there were times
when he's running around
like a headless chicken
that I've thought, "Oops.
This is all my fault."
I don't know when the penny's gonna drop
that he's good at baking.
I think he can win it.
-Good luck.
-Cheers.
[Alison] I want you
to think about you winning.
-Possibly winning.
-You got to start visualising it.
Yeah, that's what Lara says.
-Visualise.
-Start visualising you winning.
[Noel] But before any finalist
can see themselves winning…
[Dan] Don't play games.
[Noel] …they'll need to take
a long, hard look at their choux.
This is the part where I said
about trusting your instinct.
You need it to fall off in three seconds.
You know how many videos
I had to watch?
[Josh] I gotta start piping them.
I'm just looking for a bit of uniformity.
You can see my hands shaking, can't you?
Choux has a mind of its own.
[Alison] Without a dusting of icing sugar,
an éclair
won't have its classic crisp shell.
[Josh] Doing two types of choux.
[Alison] But Josh
has decided to go even further.
I'm going
for a chocolate craquelin topping.
Couple of millimetres' thickness.
Do or die now.
They go in for 40 minutes.
-[oven beeps]
-Half an hour, 175.
[Matty] Fifteen minutes at 200.
Take it down to 175 for another
15 minutes, maybe 20, maybe 25.
I want them to be dry.
Oh, no, I didn't dust 'em in icing sugar.
Too late not, innit?
-Did you put icing sugar on yours?
-Yes. Did you?
-Forgot, didn't I?
-Oh, no way.
Wouldn't be me, not forgetting something.
Josh, how you doing?
-I think okay.
-Choux looking all right?
-[Josh] Yeah.
-[Dan] Good lad.
-[Noel] How are ya?
-All over the place.
I'm dreaming.
It's the most surreal week ever.
Your kids don't know.
-I told 'em.
-You've told 'em?
I told them yesterday.
My kids don't know I do this.
-Don't they?
-No.
It's the best way,
'cause it went down like a lead balloon.
[laughing] What do you mean?
What? Nothing? Gave you nothing?
They just went, "You lied."
Gave me the father talk,
"I'm disappointed in you."
-[Noel] No. "I'm not angry. Disappointed."
-[Dan] "Disappointed."
-From the top ropes.
-[laughs]
[groans, laughs]
[Dan] This lie is the biggest burden
especially when I tell
my children, "Never lie."
Obviously, this is a slight exception.
My eldest wanders into the kitchen.
He doesn't question anything.
He goes, "What you doing, Dad?"
I'm like, "I'm making
electric guitar out of puff pastry."
He's like, "Cool."
Wanders off with his iPad.
He just thinks I'm absolutely crackers.
[boy] Mmm-hmm.
[Noel] But some members of Dan's family
know what he's been up to.
It's been very difficult keeping it quiet
and not telling the world
that my son's in [whispers] Bake Off.
I'm so proud of him.
[man] What was Dan like as a lad?
[Pat] He was a whirlwind.
He was cheeky, he was mischievous as well.
The trophies that he's won
playing football,
they used to line his bedroom walls.
It never got to his head
that he was man of the match
or player of the year.
He's very critical of himself.
I wanna make sure I put my kids in bed,
try and live that sort of normal life
and help with family stuff
as much as possible.
Soon as eight o'clock strikes,
it's in here until I'm done, basically.
So, yeah, it's totally covert,
door closed.
Luckily, they're good sleepers.
Whatever happens, I'll make sure
that I leave the tent as I came in
with a big smile on my face
'cause I've loved it.
Good luck, Dan. You'll smash it.
-Cheers, thank you.
-[all cheering]
-[interviewer] Do you think he can win?
-Yes.
I think he can.
[Dan] They're not as dark as usual.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
[Noel] As their choux bakes,
the finalists need every minute
to perfect two delicious fillings.
[Matty] Crème pat,
this is a chocolate one,
then I'll turn my attention
to the banana one.
[Dan] This is for my eldest lad,
loves his salted caramel ice cream,
so I thought to pay homage
to the wonderful boy that he is.
[Alison] Whilst Dan and Matty
race to create separate fillings
for each of their two éclairs…
Decent.
…Josh has perfected a shortcut.
[Josh] Just prepping pastry creams now.
I've been tweaking with the recipes,
so I can have
exactly the same base for both of them.
One's gonna be a coffee one.
This one has got coconut milk.
Just means I can do 'em quicker
'cause I know
it's a lot of pressure on today.
That's our VIP experience
at Gardener's World.
[Josh's dad] Very clever lad.
-He likes perfection.
-Yeah.
So he'll keep going and doing something
until he's got as best as he can get.
Nanny always has a smile on her face,
wherever we are.
[Josh] She's got
colourful necklaces like Prue.
-[Julie] Like Prue. Yes.
-[Josh's dad laughs]
[Julie] His love of baking stemmed
from being with Nanny.
My mum always fetched him out of school.
And they'd go back to her house
and then we would be baking.
[Noel] Josh's nan Frieda
first encouraged him
to apply for the Baking Show back in 2019.
Looking very smiley.
[Noel] She died in 2021.
[Julie] Nanny was a big part of him
applying the second time around.
He really wanted to do it for her because…
[softly] It's okay, darling.
She so wanted him to be on that show.
She loved all his baking.
She says, "You go for it."
And, erm… And he's gone
and he's got to the final,
and I can't believe it.
-Sorry.
-It's okay.
-Poor Mum.
-I know.
[Alison] You want it?
-Do you want it?
-I mean, it would be lovely.
Come on, Josh. You gotta--
All I'm visualising
is what my showstopper should look like.
What's the one thing
you'll miss from the tent?
You, of course.
It's the right answer.
-It's the right answer.
-[both laugh]
See you in a bit.
Apart from not putting my icing sugar on,
they're looking all right, I'm happy.
[Josh] Another five minutes
to make sure I finish those off.
[Matty] Think I'm all right
with how it looks.
Give it a minute.
Out of my depth.
[Noel] Alison's just informed me
that she went, "What you gonna miss most?"
And you said, "You," to her.
Absolutely furious.
I thought we had something, Josh.
Seven years I've done this, Josh.
-Seven years.
-[both laughing]
I'm going to prick holes in the top
to let little steamies escape.
[Matty] Chocolate crème pat is done,
Chantilly cream whipped.
Trying to multitask.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Oh, you're joking me.
Having a tin bath?
[thunder rumbling]
This is it, the storm is coming.
This is banana for the banoffee.
The choux are a minute off being done.
-[oven beeps]
-Really happy.
I can just hear
that they're hollow.
[timer beeping]
[Matty] Gonna poke
holes in 'em to release steam.
Then put 'em back for five minutes.
This just hopefully
completely dries them out.
I've left them on the bloody tray.
Now they've gone soft.
This tent does strange things to me.
Fortunately, I've got lots of good ones
so I can just pick my four favourites.
[Matty] Cherry jam.
I'm just gonna blitz this so it can
fold through into the cream.
Yeah, that's cool.
These are gonna be macerated
with summer fruit punch.
Let's see how I get on.
Ah, why is it doing that?
[Josh] Coffee pastry cream.
I'll pipe the first hole,
then I go for the second,
then stop once this first hole oozes
so I know that
I've gone all the way through.
You have 15 minutes left.
-[Dan] Not gonna be able to do it.
-[Matty] Crème pat first.
I need to get as much in as I can.
[Dan] Chantilly cream, voila.
[Josh] Icing.
[Matty] It's difficult
to get the bananas to squeeze through.
[Dan] This is my debut appearance
of a transferring onto acetate.
[Josh] Do some
very thin lines of chocolate.
[Dan] This is my praline paste.
This is going into my ganache.
You have five minutes left.
Just about okay, time-wise.
I want to finish off these other ones.
Gonna run out of filling.
Bakers, you only have one minute left.
[Matty] One minute?
I've done that
the wrong way round, you berk.
[Matty] Oh, you flipper.
[Dan] Ahhh!
[Alison] Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your
final signature challenge éclairs.
[Alison] It's judgement time
in the final signature challenge.
-Hi, Josh.
-Hello.
-[Paul] Hi.
-Hiya.
Like the look of them.
They're all pretty much the same size.
Pretty uniform across the board.
[Prue] That's perfectly filled.
I'm always so cross
when I have an empty éclair.
The flavours are very delicate.
But they are absolutely delicious.
I think, for me,
it's a little bit too sweet.
-Okay.
-[Paul] It almost needs a sharpness
to make that pop even more.
-This is the chocolate coffee?
-[Josh] Yeah.
[Paul] That's clever.
Chocolate's the right level,
it gives a lovely texture to it.
The craquelin on the top.
Coffee level is absolutely spot on,
filled well, baked well.
That's delicious.
I love coffee éclairs.
And it is perfect.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-[Paul] Cherries on top look ridiculous.
-Okay.
If you're gonna put cherry on top,
make sure it's all the same.
Start with the banana first?
Mmm.
I like the flavour of the banana.
You're missing the caramel.
I know you tried to get it on the outside.
-But for banana lovers, this is perfect.
-Thank you.
[Prue] Now that's the first one
we've had that is properly firm.
I like the Black Forest gateau.
You could've done more cherry.
-[Matty] Okay.
-The chocolate is lovely. Booze is good.
And most of all,
I like the crisp, firm éclair.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Thanks.
These look a bit messy.
-It's the wrong shape for this.
-[Dan] All right.
[Paul] Can't have something
that's too big that sits over the top
-shadowing underneath.
-[Dan] Right, okay. Got ya.
I think you've attempted too much.
They do look very soggy.
The flavour is lovely, not too sweet.
It's really strawberries and cream,
but it's soggy.
You've destroyed it
by adding too much cream.
On top. Yeah.
[Paul] This is the praline, isn't it?
Not convinced about the flavour.
-Are you not?
-It's probably the grain.
I agree that the filling
is not satin-smooth,
but I think the flavour's great.
I think it looks a mess.
[sucks teeth] Paul picked up
on all my technical issues.
And again I've been guilty
of overthinking it.
[Matty] Nine weeks ago,
I would not have been able to produce
anything like that. So… yeah.
[chuckles] Weird.
[Josh] I had quite a strong signature.
[laughing] We just got
the technical to get through.
And hopefully it isn't just,
"Step one, make this," and that's it.
I'm hoping for a bit of help
along the way.
[Alison] The bakers' last technical
challenge is as ever a total mystery.
It's time for your final
technical challenge,
and today it's been set for you
by Mr Paul Hollywood.
What can we say about Paul?
We've heard his poetry,
we've seen his dance moves,
we've seen him strip down to trunks
and wrestle a live bear.
I'm sure you've fallen in love with him
and he loves you too.
Although, he will destroy you one by one.
Paul, have you got any words of advice
for our incredible finalists?
For perfection,
you're going to need patience.
[Noel] This technical challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're gonna have to ask
these two to leave the tent.
It's the last technical challenge,
you know where they're going.
-Where?
-To make sweet, sweet love.
[all laughing]
For your final technical challenge,
Paul would like you to bake
a batch of nine lardy cake slices.
Now the judges will be looking
for perfectly laminated dough
packed with soaked fruit
and homemade candied peel.
You have three hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake!
[laughs]
Let's have a look at ya.
A lardy cake?
[Josh] I've heard the name,
but don't know what one looks like.
No one makes lardy cake, do they?
-No.
-Not since the war.
It sounds like
one from that era, doesn't it?
-Do you not know what a lardy cake is?
-No.
Oh, dear.
What a lovely nostalgic bake for a final.
Lardy cake.
We've revisited a British classic.
It's been around for hundreds of years,
and it was a way of using up
predominantly pig fat.
-But don't forget fat is flavour.
-Yeah.
So I'm really flavoursome.
[laughs]
[Paul] It's a cross
between a Danish pastry and a bread.
This is all about
getting your timing right.
Get the dough done quickly
to get it in that prover,
and then you're layering it with sugar…
-Folding it.
-…lard, butter and fruit.
On the second prove, be patient.
The longer the better.
That opens the whole thing up,
but it'll condense
if they don't bake it properly,
and it'll look and taste quite raw.
[Prue] You can see the layers. Lovely.
And you can see
all the fruit in there evenly distributed.
Lard, sugar and a bit of fruit.
[laughs] Heaven.
"Line the roasting tin
with baking paper,
then grease with lard
and sprinkle with sugar."
I assume this is gonna help
colour up the lardy cakes.
Obviously, you are
the oldest of the bakers.
-I am, yes.
-So you must know what a lardy cake is.
[both laughing]
[Matty] "Make the bread dough."
"Make the bread dough."
Fifty grams of lard.
So I'm gonna bread crumb it,
then add yeast and water.
I'll add a little bit at a time.
Add the water and then
once it comes together,
I'll put the lard in.
I don't know.
[Matty] Don't know
if I should be doing it like this.
It sounds really healthy, lardy cake.
That's the problem with baking, innit?
[mimics expanding noise]
Yeah, I've gotta do plenty of runs
once this has finished.
[exhales]
[Matty] The kneading.
[Matty] How many times
have we made a variation of bread?
Is this even bloody bread?
What is this?
Lob it in the proving drawer.
For half an hour,
but we'll see how we're doing.
I'm not happy with that,
but I'm just gonna go with it.
Bye-bye, my little cherub.
I'm gonna go for about 30 mins.
See how it looks.
Patience is the key.
"Step five, make diced candied
orange boiling twice in fresh water
and then a third time in sugar syrup."
"Using the microwave for speed,
infuse the dried fruit with the tea."
[Alison] Smells lovely.
-Put any rum in it?
-No.
[Alison] I'm from Jamaica,
I soak my fruits in rum.
-There's none.
-Any vodka?
-[chuckles] No.
-Gin?
Unfortunately, just water.
-Just water. Dry.
-Yeah. I know.
[both] With a tea bag.
[both laughing]
Finalists, you are halfway through.
[Dan mimics trumpet blowing]
That's been in for 35 minutes.
[Josh] That's been in
for 45 minutes.
"Laminate the dough with lard,
butter and filling mixture."
Doesn't say what to do with the lard.
Do you reckon I smear the lard?
[Dan] Get rocking and rolling.
I might just make sure
I've got this evenly spread.
Maybe I… brush the lard… on.
Have you had a breakdown?
What's happening here?
[laughing] Look at you
just pushing lard into pastry.
I think me and you might as well
just grease ourselves up in lard.
And just go the whole hog.
-I'm in if you are.
-I'd never turn something like that down.
[both laughing]
Lamination. Let's make
some space for lamination.
"Perform three single letter folds."
[Matty] Which is that.
Or is it… that?
[Josh] Gonna do it carefully,
I want them to see those layers.
[Dan] Spin it round 90 degrees.
Everything's a bit warm.
But that's one letter fold.
[Josh] I want the layers to be even.
[Matty] Butter's getting a bit warm.
[Dan] That's two. Stay with me, bread.
[Josh] Give it one more fold.
[Dan] I'm not liking the look of this.
-[Josh] Pleased with that.
-[Matty] It says, "Prove in tin."
[Noel] The second prove
needs to be as long as possible.
[whispers] Nice.
[Noel] Any attempt to speed it up
in the heat of the proving drawer
could melt the lard,
ruining the rise and the lamination.
Maybe I just leave it on the side.
Oh, no, yeah, put it in the drawer.
[sucks teeth] I wanna give it
half an hour prove.
Half an hour.
Erm…
I don't know how long to bake for.
If I can work out bake time…
So bake, 40?
Bakers, you have an hour left.
So that means prove only two minute--
Er, 20 minutes.
-[timer beeps]
-[chuckles]
[thunder rumbling]
[Josh] I'm going in.
It's feeling very springy,
that's what you want.
So I'm gonna put that in.
[timer beeping]
I'm gonna start with half an hour.
-Look at that.
-This is looking great. Look at that.
-The worst thing is you don't know…
-[Noel whistles]
…whether it's supposed to
look like that.
Not a clue, no.
-[laughs]
-And it doesn't look brilliant.
Bake, I'm thinking 200.
Two hundred's my
go-to temperature for bread.
Thirty?
Maybe 40, maybe 30.
Patience.
[laughing] It's, like, painful.
You have 15 minutes left.
I don't know with it.
It's had half an hour now.
I'll just give it another…
35 is what I had in my head.
[oven beeps]
I've just cranked it up
to 220 just to… [whistles]
give it a wiggle.
[whispers] I don't know.
[in normal voice] Another five.
Wants you to leave it in the tin
for ten minutes before turning out.
Okay, start that now.
I'm bringing it out.
It's dark, mind.
Looks like it's been cremated.
[Josh] "Brush the cake
with the reserved orange syrup."
"Cool completely upside down,
then cut to nine rectangles."
No chance of me cooling it completely.
How long do we have left?
Bakers, you've got five minutes left.
[Josh] Right.
[Matty snickers]
[Josh] Looks pretty tasty.
[Dan] This is very hot,
and I'll be lucky to cut it
in any way, shape or form.
I can smell the orange.
[sobs jokingly]
Looks a bit dense in places.
You can see the layers, can't you?
It's baked anyway.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your lardy cakes
and place them behind your photos.
[Dan] They're varying degrees
of weirdness.
[Alison] Paul and Prue
are expecting golden-brown lardy cakes
with clearly defined layers
and evenly packed with plump sweet fruit.
Obviously they've been
struggling with proving. Okay.
We start with this one.
We have got nine
and they are sort of square.
That one feels a little bit
light which is good.
The lamination,
you can see the lines going across.
[Prue] Mmm.
The flavour's there.
But what's so lovely
about this is the mixed peel.
I think that's really delicious.
[Prue and Paul laughing]
[Paul] Now moving on to this,
erm, King Alfred, er--
[chuckles] It's only slightly King Alfred.
Slightly?
[Prue] It's caramelised a lot.
[Paul] It is caramelised a lot. Overbaked.
So you see the layers,
they're sort of not very even.
It's a nice flavour.
It's just a little bit dry.
-Hmm, it's too dry.
-It is too dry.
Moving on.
-[Prue] This isn't properly baked, is it?
-[Paul] No.
-[Prue] Lots of fruit in it, but it's raw.
-It has got lots of fruit. Yeah.
It needed more proving as well,
but it is quite dense, this.
-But you see how quite raw that is.
-[Prue] Hmm.
[Paul] That hasn't been
laminated properly. It's a shame.
[Noel] Paul and Prue will now rank
the lardy cakes from worst to first.
Okay, in third spot, we have this one.
Whose is this?
Matty, lamination is really bad.
-Needed more proving and more baking.
-No problem.
Number two, we have this one.
Dan, stayed in the oven
a bit too long, didn't it?
Which means, in first place,
we have this one, Josh.
It's decent, right colour
and certainly the right flavour.
-So well done.
-Well done, mate.
[applause]
I'm buzzing after that.
Really, really pleased.
[Dan] Josh has probably
got his nose in front,
and me and Matty
are scrapping at the bottom.
Oh! Bloomin' hell.
I'm glad I had a good signature,
'cause otherwise I'd be a bit deflated.
[thunder rumbling]
[Noel] There's just one challenge
remaining in this year's Baking Show.
-Very quiet walk this time.
-Yeah, very quiet. In the zone.
Well, guys, we've made it to the final.
I just hope the sunshine comes out.
-It will.
-I'm gutted.
Who's bringing the sunshine right now?
-Are they even at the moment?
-It's pretty even.
I think Josh has got a slight edge.
[Prue] He is slightly ahead.
[Noel] Weirdly, Matty is sitting
in second place, I would say.
If he wins it, he would've played
an absolute blinder,
'cause he's always just
underneath the top.
[Alison] Can we talk
a little bit about Dan?
He'll struggle against the other two
at the moment,
but what often happens in the final bake
is the pressure gets to them.
Any one of 'em could win.
What about Amos?
Outsider.
Great. So, I've just put
20,000 pounds on Amos to win.
-[Prue and Alison laugh]
-It's good odds.
I bet.
Bakers, it's your final ever
showstopper challenge.
The judges would like you to create
an elegant tiered celebration cake
inspired by your very first bake.
[Noel] They would like you
to take your first bake
and elevate it into something incredible,
something that could win
the entire competition.
You have four and a half hours for this.
On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake!
Come on, Dan. Flour power is needed.
There's lots of elements to do,
so timing is what I'm most worried about.
I just know how I want it to look.
I will spend the time to make it
and that will be my downfall.
They have to make
a minimum three-tier cake
to celebrate their very first bake.
[Prue] But we're looking
for that to be the inspiration
for something completely new
and different and wonderful.
We want it highly decorated,
we want tartness,
we want sweetness, we want textures.
This is the biggest bake
they will ever do.
If it was me,
I'm a big fan of the lemon drizzle.
That would be my favourite.
But sometimes, the bakers tell us
that this is going to be a lemon cake
and it doesn't have enough lemon flavour.
You have to deliver what you say
you're going to deliver.
My first footstep into baking
was a lemon drizzle cake.
A lemon meringue pie as well,
so my three-tiered cake today
is celebrating both of those two
absolute beauties of the baking world.
[Noel] Dan's final tilt at the title
is a towering triple-tiered love letter
to lemon drizzle,
layered with lemon curd,
limoncello crème mousseline
and raspberry compote.
His showstopper will be finished
with torched Italian meringue,
shiny white chocolate collars
and one final citrus flourish.
I'm also going to make some macarons
to decorate round the outside.
Lemon macarons?
Yeah, with lemon curd
and raspberry compote filling.
He's been doing his homework.
He knows that we like lemon.
Which is fine,
because it was your first bake.
-Yeah, I love lemon.
-Which is lucky.
-Oh, okay.
-[Paul laughs]
I hope. Well, I need to do it right.
You know, Rahul made me
a lemon drizzle cake for my 50th birthday.
-Oh, did he?
-Ten years ago.
[all laugh]
[Alison] But one finalist is going even
more traditional than a lemon drizzle.
The bake that it stems from is, er,
a Victoria sponge.
It's the first one
I remember doing with my nan.
[Alison] Josh will combine his first bakes
with his other passion
in a seasonal celebration of his garden
with a spring and summer inspired
rhubarb and strawberry jam
and autumnal apple
in his Victoria sponges.
[Paul] It's tricky
to put apple into sponge.
-To get the flavour.
-Yeah.
For decoration,
what's the whole thing gonna look like?
So, the three tiers are decorated
for spring, summer and autumn.
I'm going to do
a biscuit greenhouse on top.
-With boiled sweet windows?
-Yeah, with little panels.
Oh, my goodness, Josh.
-This is a lot.
-Sounds like a showstopper.
-Keep your cool.
-[Josh] Yeah.
-I'll try.
-Thank you, Josh.
[Dan] I've gone for a stronger batter
so it doesn't lose its shape
when it gets put together.
Genoise is a little bit
of a risk, I guess,
to go on the bottom tier
because it's such a light cake.
But the pros
outweigh the cons on this one.
I've gone for it 'cause it's quick
to make, quick to bake, quick to cool.
But I've never stacked a cake
until this week.
[Noel] Inspired by the chocolate treats
that got him into baking,
Matty's first ever tiered cake
will see chocolate genoise sandwiched
with French buttercream
and crumbled brownie.
And a lemon and rosemary Victoria sandwich
with a fresh summer fruit jam.
Now that you're a baker, do you think
you'll bring baking into school?
What bake would you bring to your kids?
[Matty] The brownies.
I've already brought them to 'em once,
but they think Lara made 'em. [laughs]
-Really?
-Yeah.
So you lied,
"My girlfriend's brought them"?
Yeah.
Why though? What is so embarrassing
about people knowing you're a baker?
No, I don't know, really.
You don't have to lie any more
-because your bakes taste amazing.
-[laughs]
[Noel] How these final showstopper taste
could prove even more important
than the spectacular look.
I want the cake to be strong with lemon,
but not too sort of, like, urgh.
[Josh] I want to have the essence
of Victoria sandwich,
but I also want to elevate it.
So, this is my rhubarb.
They're not my strawberries
because I ran out.
They've been ravaged from
all of the past weeks that I've done.
[Alison] But past weeks may not bode well
for Matty's chosen flavours.
In week one,
I had a stinker with the buttercream.
So, I've changed the recipe slightly.
I kind of need to learn in my own way.
Takes me a few mistakes
to… to learn. [laughs]
[Dan] Slightly worried about time.
[Alison] For three tiers, the finalists
will need to bake at least six sponges.
-[Josh] Seven minutes left.
-[Alison] Which will require batch baking…
Have a look at that brownie
in a second and all.
-…and a constant eye on the clock.
-[timer beeping]
[timer stops beeping, clatters]
[chuckles]
I've stopped it.
Imagine if that hit Josh in the eye.
And he had to go to hospital
and the whole thing was cancelled.
One way to stop him winning it.
[Matty] What we onto now?
[Dan] Done, happy with that.
I can start to make the next batter.
I'm gonna go on my second mix.
Four and a half hours, is it enough time?
So, er, I think it's ample, right? No?
[laughing]
[Dan] See how they get on.
-[Josh] Pretty happy with that.
-[Matty] These are going in.
It's now all on me
getting the bakes done quick enough
that I can have enough time.
[Noel] But Dan will need to find the time
to bake more than just sponges.
I'm only on step four.
[laughs] Ridiculous.
The idea of a macaron
is to get a nice skin on them.
So once I've piped them,
I'm gonna leave 'em for a good hour.
[Josh] Let's get these in.
This is the Swiss meringue buttercream,
so I've got two on the go.
Plus, a bit of cake.
That's got about eight minutes to go.
Whilst they're in the tin
and still warm,
make some holes in it
and then some lemon juice on.
[imitates Paul] "Too much lemon in that,
Dan." Sorry, Paul.
[Noel] Bakers, you're halfway through!
-What?
-I know.
Love these ovens.
I think they're done, they're a bit, like,
not straight, but I'll have to trim that.
Just tasted the curd,
that tastes beautiful.
I've done that, done that…
You've got a big list
you're working through.
Yeah, look. The buttercreams are made.
The jam's made.
-[Noel] Not too bad.
-This part is where it gets…
-Crazy.
-…hard.
-Is that assembly?
-Yeah.
[Alison] If constructing
a three-tiered cake wasn't hard enough…
It's the assembly and making it
look pretty is where I'm pants.
…whilst building,
Dan still has baking to do.
Well behind. It's all right, I'll do it.
[Alison] But he's not alone.
What's going down here?
-This is my, er, greenhouse on top.
-[laughs]
You're like da Vinci.
Got enough time
to do everything you wanna do?
[Josh] I'll never have enough time
to do everything I'd love to do.
Have you factored that in?
Of course you have.
[Josh] Yeah, I've got
a couple of backups.
That's why I love you. [laughs]
In case things don't go to plan.
Plan B and a plan C in your back pocket.
Matty could be in need of his own plan B.
[Matty] That one's
a little bit not too done.
[Noel] The sponges for his middle tier
are underbaked.
That's a bummer. How long do we have?
Bakers, you have one hour left.
[Matty] Can I go home now, please?
[softly] Come on, Josh, come on.
[Matty] Five minutes at really high.
And then I'll put 'em
straight in the freezer.
Probably will affect the bake slightly,
erm, but it is what it is.
I've got my meringue to do as well.
Flipping heck.
I don't think I'm gonna do it. Help.
Once I've got these out the oven,
we'll start doing the assembly.
[Matty] We've got chocolate genoise,
Swiss meringue and then
a chocolate French buttercream
and then brownie.
Let's have a little gander.
I'd say them two are done.
I don't know,
but I haven't got that much time left.
[Dan] Whose stupid idea was this?
That's the last lot of panels.
Beautiful, right.
-[oven beeps]
-That can go off now.
[Dan] I'm inserting dowels.
Oh, I need to put the dowels in,
actually, as well.
[Josh] White chocolate buttercream.
We need to get going with cake.
[Matty] And then freezer.
-[Josh] That's the first one done.
-[Dan] Right, come on.
Forty minutes.
[Matty] Bit of summer fruit jam.
[Dan] I just need to get it in the fridge
for as long as it takes.
Nearly there.
[Dan] Right, macarons.
Done the middle layer with strawberry
and rhubarb jam. Doing the final layer.
Just swapping the tiers.
So how long do we have left?
Bakers, you only have half an hour left.
Yeah, I'm happy with that. Right.
Oh, you're joking me. These should just
basically peel off perfectly.
Come on, you stupid thing.
Oh. It's cracking.
[Matty] Let's see how much I learnt
from Lara's art lesson.
[Dan] Look a bit underdone actually.
Too soft.
I just don't think I probably
made the batter well enough.
But deal with it. I need to
collect my thoughts for a second.
Number two.
Lara said you have
to build up the colour.
Be patient and always go
in the same direction.
-You okay?
-No.
[Noel] You need it all to go smoothly.
-[Dan] Yeah.
-[Noel] Dig deep.
-You can do this.
-I can do it.
[Alison] Where did you
get this design from?
It's kind of like, 'cause I'm not good
at doing it any other way.
No, but it works though,
it looks really arty.
[Josh] This is going to be
spring at the top.
Why did I choose to temper chocolate?
It's gonna look very rushed, this.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
[Josh] Come on.
[Dan] Don't swear, Dan.
We're getting to the critical point,
where I need to stack it.
Don't want it to lean.
[Dan] Dog's dinner.
[Josh] Want to put the greenhouse on,
then I can finish.
Any time I've got spare,
I'll do some decoration.
[Dan] How's long's left?
Looking good, bakers,
you have ten minutes left.
[Josh] I'm gonna have to rush
a lot of decoration.
[Dan] Need a blowtorch.
Don't know why I'm even bothering.
[Matty] Gold leaf out of it.
These are my giant marrows
that I harvest in the autumn.
I'll hide it with a macaron,
Paul and Prue will never notice.
I wanna do some piping
round the outside of it
to make it look a little bit fancier.
How long we got left now?
One minute left.
[Dan] It's messy, too messy.
Don't look behind ya and look at Josh's.
Bakers, your time is now up.
Walk away rapidly. [chuckles]
[Alison] Please step away
from your bakes. We love you.
Well done.
Come on, bring it in, mate, bring it in.
Well done, boys.
-Goodbye, Paul.
-[Josh] Got buttercream over your back.
[Dan] Don't worry about it.
Oh, no. My mistake.
You got four minutes left.
[laughing]
[indistinct chatter]
[Noel] The winner
of this year's Baking Show
will be announced
at a very special garden party
in front of the bakers' families
and some old friends.
I'm back at the tent. It's so exciting.
Just like one wee family
all together again.
[Abbi] We've got a group chat
where we all talk,
post pictures of what we've been doing,
and that's lovely.
It's so nice to be here and not be baking
and just feel like you can enjoy
all the wonderful cakes
that have been made.
In my mind, I think Dan's going to win,
but I think it's gonna be so close.
They're all incredible,
all good at different things.
I literally can't call it.
If I had to say someone, maybe Josh.
Either Dan or Josh or Matty.
One of those.
I think Matty could surprise everyone.
It's probably like asking a parent
to pick their favourite child,
it's a very difficult call, Josh.
Dan, for one last time,
bring up your showstopper.
Dan, tell us all about
your final showstopper.
So, this is my lemon drizzle
and meringue cake
with a lemon curd and raspberry compote,
topped with Italian meringue
and decorated with some macarons
filled with the lemon curd
and raspberry compote.
I like the white chocolate against
the raspberry, I like the meringue.
The macarons are terrible.
-Dunno what's gone on with 'em.
-I wouldn't put them on.
-[Dan] Yeah.
-[Paul] 'Cause it sort of ruins it.
I did think it was quite ambitious
to do three chocolate collars.
-[Paul] It's cracked quite a bit.
-Yeah.
Looks a lovely sponge.
-[Prue] Doesn't it?
-[Paul] Really nice.
-You know, it needs more lemon.
-Does it?
The drizzle only comes in to so far
-and then it stops so…
-Ah, okay.
But the flavour is delicious
and I think the bake is lovely as well.
-Macarons let it down dramatically.
-Yeah.
-And the bake's not right.
-[Dan] I don't know what's gone on.
It's really pasty.
Have I not cooked them
for long enough?
[Paul] No, you definitely haven't.
-No, I've not, have I?
-No.
It's just a little bit flawed for me.
Work to be done for next week.
[all laughing]
-Thanks, buddy.
-[Dan] Thanks very much.
Matty, would you like to bring up
your showstopper please?
Matty, tell us about your showstopper.
The top and bottom tier
are inspired by a chocolate cake.
So, it's a chocolate genoise sponge
with a French chocolate buttercream
and chocolate brownie
coated in a Swiss meringue buttercream.
Middle tier is a Victoria sponge,
so it's lemon and rosemary
with summer fruit jam
and a American buttercream.
-It's leaning a bit. Did you put--
-Dramatic effect.
-[chuckles]
-[Paul] What happened?
I mustn't have done
much of a job with the dowels.
I must say, Matty,
I love the colour combinations.
And the way you've done it.
I like the decoration,
the piping, the fruit,
-the drop is the big problem.
-Yeah, it's done me.
[Paul] But let's see
what's it's like inside.
Wow, that's one light sponge.
-[laughs] Oh. Wow.
-[Prue] That looks beautiful, doesn't it?
I mean, I'm surprised
it weighs enough to cause the lean.
-[Paul] What a great cake.
-Thanks.
[Paul] Now the chocolate's coming in,
it's a light chocolatey, moreish sponge.
-It's absolutely delicious.
-Hmm.
I have no good reason to having
another bite, but I've got to.
-I love the jam.
-I like the cake.
It reminds me of some of the nice
birthday cakes I had when I was a kid.
It's a beautiful sponge.
-[Prue] All the flavours are perfect.
-Thank you.
Really perfect, Matty.
There's nothing wrong
with this cake except it's on the lean.
That's such a pity,
because it's only one mistake.
-Yeah.
-[Prue] Everything else
is absolutely perfect.
-Thank you.
-[Matty] Thank you.
-Well done, Matty lad. Awesome, mate.
-Thank you.
Good luck, mate.
Do you need a hand
getting it off the table?
I think I'll be okay. We'll see.
Josh, it's time for your showstopper.
Josh, tell us all about
your final showstopper.
I've called this showstopper
"A Slice For All Seasons."
It's all representing the seasons
in the garden.
It's inspired by a Victoria sandwich,
so the bottom tier
is an apple and lemon sponge
with a lemon curd
and a white chocolate buttercream.
The top two tiers are the same.
They're an apple and vanilla sponge
with a strawberry and rhubarb jam
and a white chocolate buttercream
in as well.
It's got a Swiss meringue buttercream
on the outside.
And my biscuit greenhouse on top.
I think the greenhouse is great
and the colours are beautiful.
[Paul] It is straight and it is level.
The pipework is not very neat.
You could've spent
another half hour on that
to create a much more polished image.
Do you want to keep this intact
or can I taste the biscuit?
You can taste.
There's some strawberry in the biscuit
and they're mints used for the panels.
[crunching]
Very clever that.
It's a sugar biscuit, isn't it?
Yeah. Bound together with some--
-[Paul] Really minty, isn't it?
-Hmm, it is minty.
Thank you, I really like that.
[Prue chuckles]
[Paul] Let's look
and see if we can try this spring.
Mmm. Jam is perfect.
I like the sponge.
I'm not getting any apple.
It hasn't showed up to the party.
-No, you can't taste the apple.
-No.
You've gone with the rhubarb
and strawberry.
It needs something more.
Okay.
This one's got a little compressed
with the weight of the others.
-[Josh] Yeah.
-[Paul] Hmm.
[Prue] Mmm.
Lovely lemon curd.
The lemon curd's nice. Got a nice flavour.
I think you need
another layer of lemon curd.
I question whether
that sponge is overbaked.
I think your flavours are adequate,
and for me, I wanted to see much more
of your journey in the tent in that cake.
I think boring is too strong a word,
but it's on its way.
It's not your best shot.
Thanks, Josh.
-[Paul] Thanks, Josh.
-Thank you.
He was being a bit harsher
because I've set my own standards
on my showstoppers…
[hesitates] …and I know the finesse
wasn't probably quite there as I'd like.
I don't know who's gonna win.
I think it might be between
me and Matty. Maybe.
Erm, hopefully I've done enough
with yesterday as well. Maybe.
[exhales heavily] I've got absolutely
no idea to be--
Honestly, I don't feel like
I'm gonna win it.
I think it's between them two, personally.
Blimey.
That could be enough.
[all cheering]
Hey!
Hello, you. Come here.
[Noel] Whilst the bakers
are reunited with their families,
Prue and Paul
have a huge decision to make.
That's it,
we've done the last showstopper.
Pretty good cake.
Just stick your fingers in all of 'em,
you'll be all right, Sammy. [laughs]
[Noel] You are always
telling Dan to simplify.
Today he definitely did simplify,
but he didn't get all the elements right.
But with Josh,
you've never told him to simplify,
and usually his showstoppers are,
they're a bit more clever.
I don't think that the decoration
was defined enough,
and it wasn't up to his usual standards.
But he's still in line for winning
because he had a good day yesterday.
[Alison] He did.
And I think Matty has also pushed himself
into that possibility of winning as well.
Because of what he's done today
and because of his flavours.
[Prue] The only thing wrong with Matty's…
-It was on the wonk.
But then you look at yesterday.
In the signature, they were very close.
Josh won the technical
and Matty came third in the technical.
[Paul] Matty was bottom.
Technical yesterday was really good.
I'm really pleased with that.
-It is tight.
-I wouldn't wanna be in your shoes.
-I want a cup of tea and another slice.
-Okay.
Can I be the person who actually announce
the winner? That's all I want.
You should do it
'cause it's probably your last year.
[Alison and Prue laugh]
You all right, mate?
Yeah, I just need a nervous wee.
[Dan] I'm getting that way as well.
[all cheering]
[imperceptible]
First, we'd like to thank everyone
for coming on this beautiful sunny day,
and I'd like to invite up
the three finalists.
Round of applause for Dan…
[cheering, whistling]
Josh and Matty.
[all cheering]
Obviously, we'd want
every single one of you to win.
But there can only be one winner.
So, gives me great pleasure
to announce that the winner
of 2023 goes to…
Matty!
[all cheering]
-Well done, darling.
-[Matty] Thank you.
Congratulations.
-Well done, mate.
-[Matty] Thank you very much.
-[Matty] Oh, thank you, mate.
-Congratulations.
[Matty] Bloody hell.
-Would you believe that?
-[Paul] What do you reckon?
You won, mate.
-[Matty] Bloody hell. Thank you, Paul.
-[Paul laughs]
[indistinct chatter]
I dunno what to say.
[all cheering]
-[Matty] Thank you.
-Well done!
People said, "You should go on Bake Off,"
and I thought it was a throwaway comment.
Never really listened to it.
I never thought
that I would be on… on… on this.
Let alone win it.
Where am I gonna put this? [laughs]
I can't even have it on show for a while.
[Rowan] Well done! Oh, my God.
[Josh] So chuffed for Matty.
When it always comes to the cakes,
he has been fantastic,
he's such a worthy winner
and a lovely chap as well.
[Alison] You're only the winner.
-How amazing is that?
-He was going home six times.
[all laughing]
[Dan] I had a feeling Matty was gonna win.
He's done it on the day it counted
and I am honestly so happy for him.
What a kid. I absolutely love him.
[all] Aw.
[Prue] I've never met a more cheerful,
smiling, uncomplaining and willing baker.
He just was having a good time,
learning as much as he could,
taking on board
everything either of us said.
And he's just got better
and better and better.
And if you're gonna smash it,
you do it in the last challenge,
and that's what he did.
That chocolate cake
was one of the best chocolate cakes
I've had for a long, long time.
[Matty] Lara. Lara, I need ya.
There's been so many ups and downs,
so many times
where I've had to be pulled through
by the people closest around me.
Certainly Lara.
I can't imagine I've been too fun
to live with in the last ten weeks.
I'm happy for them as much
as I am for me with this one.
[all cheering]
[Matty] It still doesn't feel real.
I dunno, I don't really know.
[interviewer] What was it
that got you here?
Lara. [laughs]
-[all cheering]
-Thank you. Sorry.
Look at him.
-Oh, God. Sorry, Paul. [laughs]
-Get outta the camera, will ya?
[both laughing]
Bye!
[closing theme music playing]